Hatun bir dakika gelsene yeni Marif
modelde ben sana bir bardak su ikram
etmek istiyorum bunu her zaman yapmam
bana bunu tarif eder misin algoritmik
bir dille sürahiyi al bardağa
koy öyle değil sürahiyi al suyu
boşalt ya
o sürahiyi al bardağın içine
boşalt ya K Bırakır mısın Bırakır mısın
Bırakır mısın Bırakır çok doldur boşalt
dedin sürahiyi al kapağını aç sürahiden
biraz bardağın içine su
koy ya biraz
Serken o kadar biraz değil sürahiyi al
kapağını aç sürahinin içinden bardağın
içine bardağın yarısını Dolduracak kadar
su boşalt sürahi yerine koy
Teşekkür ederim bardağı ver demedim
abi kendisi kendime alırım Algoritma da
suyuna da
alam Selamlar rm Tayfa Ben Mehmet hocan
güncel müfredatta öğretmeninden
öğrencisine en çok zorlanılan ve hatta
en çok merak edilen temaya gelmiş
bulunmaktayız 5 tema Algoritma ve
bilişim diyeceğiz ve emin ol burayı en
detaylı şekilde benden dinleyeceksin en
güzel püf noktalarıyla benden
dinleyeceksin sorularına geçtiğimizde en
rahat şekilde işte orada O soruları Sen
çözeceksin hiç merak etme Diğer
konularda yaptığımız gibi bu konuda da
algoritmada da tamamen ne yapacağız
detaylı bir şekilde analiz edeceğiz
sorularını beraber çözeceğiz ÖSYM gerek
map hangi sınavda sorarsa sorsun fark
etmez algoritmayla gelen soruları
birlikte devireceğiz amacımız o
ayrıntılı bir doküman hazırladım seninle
birlikte şimdi onu beraber ne yapacağız
dolduracağız Ama senden ricam Ders
notlarını alıyorsun önüne koyuyorsun
benimle birlikte yazıyor benimle
birlikte çözüyorsun Hazır mısın o zaman
elimizde kalemler önümüzde Algoritma
ders notları o taraf sende bu taraf
bende matematik de bende o zaman gönder
Gönder gelsin Hocam diyorum Evet o çok
merak edilen 5 TEMAD dayız algoritmanın
işlem adımları 1 diyeceğiz birinci
derste mevzuya başlayacağız Tabii ki her
zaman olduğu gibi tanımla başlayacağım
Hani Aslında algoritmada genel anlamda
şunu yapacağız bir bilgisayar programı
yazmaya çalışacağız Bazıları için çok
eğlenceli olacak Hatta hayatını
değiştirecek bazı konulardan biri
diyebilirim Ben buna ilgisi artacak
hemen gidip bir evde bilgisayarda
denecek bazılarımız İsa Belki de hiç
sevmeyecek Çünkü herkesin bu tarafa
ilgisi olmayabilir bu doğal bir şey ama
İlgin olursa ileride İyi para
kazanabilirsin gerçi bilmiyorum yani
yazılım işi artık ileride para etmeyecek
diyorlar Yapay Zeka sebebiyle ama
göreceğiz Şimdi Algoritma nedirle
başlıyoruz Algoritma nedir arkadaş
belirli bir problemi çözmek veya bir
amaca ulaşmak için için adım adım
uygulanan kuralların tüm bütününe
verilen isim
algoritmadan temel felsefesinde şu
vardır açıklık anlaşılırlık ve
sistematik bir yapı olması gerekir
algoritmanın genel mantığında bu var
şimdi buradan soru gelmez tabii ki
sınavda ama benim derdim sadece soru
değil sana bu işin felsefesini anlatmak
geldim ikinci Başlığa algoritmaların
işleyiş biçimi ki bizim asıl üstünde
duracağımız nokta bu Algoritma bir
süreci başlangıç noktasından bir bitiş
noktasına doğru adım adım yönlendirir
bir başlangıç yapacağız bir bitiş
noktası belirleyeceğiz O noktaya doğru
adım adım adım ilerleyeceğiz
algoritmanın amacı gereken işlemleri
sıralı ve net bir şekilde açıklamaktır
ve Biz bu işlemleri yaparken algoritmada
ü farklı yöntem kullanacağız işte
kullanacağımız yöntemlerden birincisi ve
bu derste anlatacağım yöntem algoritmik
doğal dil ikincisi akış şeması üçüncüsü
de sözde kotu olacak Her bir derste ayrı
ayrı sana Ben bunları Zaten aktar Maya
devam edeceğim Ama ilk olarak Dediğim
gibi az önce ne dedim algoritmik doğal
dil Hocam bu algoritmik doğal dil nedir
burayı anladıktan sonra emin ol akış
şeması ve Sözde kod çok daha kolay
olacak ama önce Neyi anlaman gerekiyor
algoritmik doğal dille ifade etmeyi
öğren gerisi hemen çok kolay yani çok
zorlamayacak seni ama önemli olan burayı
halletmemiz burayı Hallettik mi gerisi
kolay algoritmik doğal dil nedir Nasıl
kullanılır Nasıl işlem yapılır burada
bir kere problemin çözüm adımlarını
günlük dil dil kullanarak anlatacaksın
çok basit Çok temel bir dil kullanarak
anlatman gerekiyor basit ve sıralı bir
yapıda sahip olman gerekiyor tıpkı o Su
doldurma algoritmasının yazılışı gibi
tek tek tane tane basit Hani bizim bir
lafa hocam mala anlatır gibi anlatır
mısın var ya maldan da öte abi hani öyle
bir anlatalım ki herkes anlasın her şey
anlasın yani taş toprak bile anlasın
yani öyle anlatmamız lazım Hani bazen
yazıyorsunuz anlat hocam Mallı anlat
gibi abi tamam edisi bir yanana Harbiden
öyle anlatacaksın ama algoritmik doğal
dil adımlarını yaparken şuna dikkat
edeceksin önce en başta sana bir problem
verilecek bu problemi önce kafanda
adımlara böl tamam mı O adımları sonra
yazılı hale getir 1ci adım ve 5 adım 5ci
adım dediğime bakma son adım diyelim biz
buna giriş ve çıkış adımlarımız
kesinlikle şunlar olmak zorunda başla ve
bitir Bunu tıpkı bir bilgisayarın başına
geldin eline mouse'unu aldın programı Ne
yapman lazım önce başlatmanın çift
tıklaman lazım program çalışacak Öyle
değil mi he İşte buradaki mantık da odur
algoritmada birinci adımımız neyle
başlamak zorunda başta adımıyla
başlayacak en sona da artık bitir
adımıyla programı kapatacak çıkacaksın
gibi hayal edebilirsin aradakiler Ne
olacak çözüm adımları olacak şimdi bu
çözüm adımlarını nasıl yazacağımız
beraber konuşacağız ama yazarken
öncelikle neye dikkat etmelisin işte
şuna bir başta komutuyla başlayacaksın
bitir komutuyla bitireceksin dedik K
bilgiser programı Aslında bu başlay la
başlanır bitir le bitirilir yani o adımı
bile yazacak mıyım hocam e Yazacaksın
tabii problemi küçük parçalara bölerek
adım adım ilerleyeceğiz o ara adımların
her biri küçük adımlar olacak çözüm
adımlarını günlük Anlaşılır bir dil
kullanarak sırasıyla ve sade biçimde
anlatacağız çok sade olacaksın ayrıntıya
girmeyeceksin çok misal şimdi bu temel
örneği beraber burada hazır çözüm
üzerinden ilerleyelim sonra Kendimiz de
yazacağız bunları ki çok bol örneğim var
hiç merak etme bir karenin alanını bulan
algoritmanın işleyişini doğal dille
ifade ediniz doğal dille ası ne şu
algoritmik doğal dille bunu ifade etmeni
istiyor Ne dedim birinci adımda
öncelikle şunu yapmak zorundasın bir
başta komutunu vermek zorundasın bunu
yazacağız Evet birazdan yazacağız zaten
buradakiler birebir yazılacak olanlar
ikinci adım şu ifade yazacağın şey değil
senin bir girdi alman lazım şimdi
karenin alanını bulmak istiyorum normal
şartta karenin alanı nasıl bulunur bir
tane Kenar uzunluğu alınır O Karen kenar
uzunluğunun karesi bulunur alanı bulunur
bu kadar basit hocam ama bunu karşıya
adeta bir mala anlatır gibi anlatm lazım
Burada girdiye ihtiyacım var şimdi orada
Hayal etmeye çalış bir bilgisayar
programı başlat dedin açıldı önce senden
ne isteyecek O Karenin bir kenarının
uzunluğunu isteyecek O yüzden Karenin
bir kenarının uzunluğunu al çok temel O
zaman artık bunu aldın mı hocam ikinci
adıma geçebilir miyiz Evet geçebilirsin
Pardon bir sonraki adıma geçebilir miyim
ki O benim 3üncü adımım oldu Şimdi artık
ne yapacağım girdiyi aldığıma göre alanı
hesaplayabilirim karenin alanı nasıl
hesaplanıyordu bir kenarın kendisiyle
çarpımı ya da karesini al Orası sana
kalmış karenin alanı kenar uzunluğunun
kendisiyle çarpımına eşittir kenar
uzunluğunun karesine eşittir abiciğim
Sen orada nasıl ifade etmek istiyorsan
et burada tek bir doğru yok farklı
yollardan da aynı yola aynı doğruya
ulaşabiliriz bu işlemi gerçekleştir Evet
bildiğim bana anlatır bir gerçekleştir
buldum gerçekleştirdim Şimdi artık bunu
bana bir çıktı olarak göstermesi lazım
tamam hesapladı ama bunu bana henüz
göstermedi bu komutu da yazmak zorunda
mıyım Evet sonucun yazdırılması adımında
Bunu bana bir iletmek zorunda bir
şekilde hesaplanan alanı ekrana ya da
bir dosyaya yazdır artık orada nereye
istiyorsa onu yazdıracağız ve artık
tekrar ne yapmam lazım programı bitirme
vakti geldi programı bitir diyeceğiz bu
kadar ben burada 5 adımda dik Pardon
karenin alanının oluşmasını sana adım
adım göstermeye çalıştım şimdi adım adım
seninle birlikte bu soruları beraber
çözeceğiz ve bu soruları çözdükçe
çözdükçe anlaşılır hale gelecek farklı
kaynaklarda farklı çözüm metotları var
ama hepsini derleyip baktığımızda en net
en güzel çözüm yolunun emin ol aklına en
yatar çözüm yolunun şimdi yapacağım
çözüm yolu olduğunu sen de anlayacaksın
Şimdi Amacımız ne hocam Neyi bulmak
istiyoruz dikdörtgenin alanını bulan
işleyişi algoritmik doğal dil ile ifade
ediniz bir kere soruyu algoritmik doğal
dil ile Yani benim Az önce öğrendiğim
dille çözmem istiyor bu dil nasıl
işliyordu hocam adım adım işliyordu
birinci adımımız nedir birinci adımımız
şudur arkadaş neye ihtiyacımız var başla
komutuna ihtiyacımız var o yüzden başla
komutunu beraber yazıyoruz ikinci adım
dikdörtgenin alanını bulmak için
öncelikle bana iki Kenar uzunluğu
gerekiyor o yüzden ne olacak 1 kenar
uzunluğunu gir kenar uzunluğunu gir bak
Bunları tek tek yazmak zorundasın gir ki
Birazdan bir açıklama daha yapacağım
sonra 2 kenar uzunluğunu gir uzunluğunu
gir Bunu da tek tek böyle yazıyorum ama
anlaşılır bir dilde olmasına dikkat
ediyorum burada mavi ile yazdıklarım
bizim asıl sınavda yazmamız gereken
şeyler Şimdi içerisine siyahla a ve b
değerleri yazıyorum aslında gireceğim
değerler Bunlar olsun Örneğin a değeri
Örneğin B değeri ikinci Kenar uzunluğu
olarak düşündüğüm şey de B değeri artık
3üncü adıma geçebilirim 3üncü adımım ne
olacak dikdörtgenin alanı dikdörtgenin
alanını hesapla dik
dörtgenin alanını hesapla alanını
hesapla komut komut tane tane
anlatıyoruz Tamam iyi güzel de
dikdörtgenin alanı nı hesaplanıyor benim
onu da anlatmam lazım onu nasıl
anlatacağım dikdörtgenin alanı eşittir
diyorum 1 kenar Evet çarpı 2 kenar doğru
mudur şu kenarı biraz daha yakın yazalım
2 kenar Aynen Komutları tek tek verdim
Şimdi yanına yazacağım siyahla Yazacağım
ifade dikdörtgenin alanını ifade etsin x
biliyorsun ki birinci kenarı a olarak
aldık ikinci kenarı B olarak aldık
Normal şartlarda MB kitabında da
görürsün Normalde algoritmik doğal dille
yaz dediğinde bu Mavileri yazıyor yanına
işlem adımlarını göstermek için de bu
siyahlarla ayrı yazıyor Ama ben bunların
hepsini tek bir adımda tek bir seferde
gösteriyorum çok daha anlaşılır çok daha
net olduğunu düşünüyorum Bu şekilde
geldim 4 adıma Artık bunun çıktısını
almam lazım Doğru mu alan sonucunu
ekranda göster alan sonucunu ya da alan
neyin hocam olmaz dikdörtgenin alanına
dik dör çok temel felsefeyle çocuğa
anlatır gibi bebeğe anlatır gibi
hayattan hiçbir bilgisi olmayan sı
sadece senin dediklerini anlayabilen
yetisi olan birini anlatıyormuş gibi
dikdörtgenin alanını alanını ekrana yaz
ekrana yaz ki ekrana yazacağı cümleyi de
bak buraya yazıyoruz dikdörtgenin alanı
dikdörtgenin alanı genin
alanı alanı x birim karedir bak ekranda
da yazmasını istediğim cümle bu bitti mi
Hayır bitmedi artık 5 adımdasın 5 adımda
ne yapıyorsun diyorsun ki hocam bitir
bitir kunda ne yapmak zorundasın vermek
zorundasın olay mevzu Gerçekten bu kadar
şimdi Adım Adım Adım Adım farklı
sorularla bu yeteneğimizi Biz de
geliştirelim şimdi önümdeki soruya bak
uzun kenarın uzunluğu 12 birim kısa
kenar uzunluğu 7 birim olan bir
dikdörtgenin alanını bulan algoritmanın
işleyişini algoritmik doğal dille
yazınız Aslında Yukarıdaki adımların
aynısı dikkat et Yukarıdaki adımlar
herhangi bir birim uzunluğu vermeden
yapılan işlemlerle şimdi aynı adımları
Aslında baştan sona tekrar yazacağım ama
yazarken tek farkım ne bu sefer artık
benden veriler belli mi birinci kenar
uzunluğunu gir ki birinci Kenar uzunluğu
nedir 12 birim a kenarını bak ne aldım
12 birim aldım ikinci Kenar uzunluğu ya
da kısa kenar uzunluğu artık bir kenar
ikinci kenar yazmama gerek yok Örneğin
algoritmanın yazılışında şunu
yapabilirim uzun kenar uzunluğunu gir
girdi A eşittir Hatta uzun kenara yine a
kalsın fark etmez u diyebilirsin
kısaltmak için buraya da kısa kenar
uzunluğunu gir hani neyi nereye
gireceğimiz kafamıza hiç karışmaması
adına adeta 0dan bilgi verdiğim için 7
birim bunu da yazabilir miyim yazarım
şimdi ne yapacağım dikdörtgenin alanını
hesapla dikdörtgenin alanı neye eşittir
uzun kenar çarp kısa kenar Hadi gel
Buradaki verileri de değiştirelim şimdi
uzun kenar yazıyorum bunlar benim asıl
yazmam gerekenler işlemsel adımlar ise
nedir aşağıda siyahla gösterdiğim
adımlar oluyor uzun kenar çarpı kısa
kenar dikdörtgenin alanını neyle
Gösterdim xile Gösterdim ne yapacağım 12
Bu arada normal noktayla değil Eski usul
çarpma işlemiyle biz şeyde
bilgisayarlarda çarpma işlemlerini
yaparız Excel kullanan arkadaşlar
bilirler noktayla değil oradaki küçük x
tuşuna Basarız çarpma işlemini
yapabilmek için ya da Yıldız tuşu
diyeyim daha doğrusu o Hatta bilgisayar
kodlamalar şu şekilde Yıldız atılır ama
ben şimdilik burada doğal Logar
logaritma diyorum algoritmik deil de
normal çarpı işlemi koyacağım buraya
Şimdi artık x'i hesaplayabilir mi
hesaplar ne gelir 2 kere 7 14'ün 4ü
elimde var bir 84 birimkare elde eder
artık yazacağı Değer ne olur
dikdörtgenin alanını ekrana yaz Bak
dikdörtgenin alanı 84 birim
şeklinde ne yapacak yazacak ha buraya 84
yazmasam bile x birim kedir yazsam bile
aslında bu bilgiyi alacak bilgisayar
kodlama zaten o x yerine ne yazacak 84
yazacak buradaki değerler değişse bile
Sonuçta ekrana yazdıracağız şey bilgiler
ışığında x ne çıkarsa onu yazmış olacak
Yine ne yapacaksın burada bitir
diyeceksin Hocam ben buraya işte 84
yazdım yanlış olur abiciğim yanlış olmaz
onu da yazabilirsin buna özel yazmış
olursun sadece 12 ve 7'ye özel yazmış
olursun Çünkü ekranda yazacak sayıyı
sabitlemiş oldun Anlaştık mı Ama hayır
hocam arka planda algoritmik dilde
oluşan bütün adımları görmek istiyorum
dediğinde de Ha o zaman buraya 84 de
yazabilirsin bir şey fark etmeyecek
tamam mı aynı doğrulukta olacak Onu bir
söyleyeyim ben sana şimdi geldim artık
yeni model bir soruya geçiyoruz ama ilk
iki sorumda özellikle burada
dikdörtgenin alanın mantığını Anladın
şimdi MEB'in örneğinde de yalan yer alan
benzer bir örneği yapacağım Aslında
bölme işleminin örneğini yapacağım 16
sayısının 5 ile bölümünden kal alanı
tekrarlı çıkarma yöntemiyle bulan
algoritmanın işleyişini algoritmik doğal
dil ile yazınız Bak aslında Özünde
benden istediği şey ne biliyor musun 16
sayısını 5'e böleceğim 3 kere 5 15 kalan
kaç 1 kalanın 1 olduğunu bana şununla
göster diyor tekrarlı çıkarma yöntemiyle
Allah Allah bu nedir hocam diyeceksin
Aslında zor bir yanı yok tekrar tekrar
16'dan 5'i çıkaracağım bölme işlemi ne
zaman biter Bak dur biz ya da yavaş
yavaş adım adım başlayalım Tabii burada
temel matematik bilginin olması
gerekiyor Bu adımları yazabilmenin
Öncelikle birinci adımımız neydi her
zaman olduğu gibi önce başlatma komutunu
vereceksin 2ci adıma artık geçebilirsin
ikinci adım Sana ne lazım veriler lazım
O halde bölen sayıyı bölünen sayıyı gir
çünkü 16 sayısının 5 ile bölümünden
bölünen bölünen sayıyı gir sayıyı sayıyı
gir sayıyı gir ardından bölen sayıyı gir
benim verilere ihtiyacım var bölen
sayıyı gir Öncelikle verileri topluyorum
Peki topladım bu verilerin her birine
isim verebilirim bölen bölünen sayıya a
diyeyim ki benim a Sayım kaç 16 bölünen
sayıya bölen sayıya özür dilerim B
diyeyim oradaki Sayım kaç 5 ki bu
verileri de işlemsel adımlar için
göstermiş oluyorum geldim 3 adıma 3
adımda ne yapmak istiyorum Benim derdim
ne tekrarlı çıkarma yöntemini kullan
tekrarlı yazıyorum tekrar
çıkarma yöntemini çıkarma yöntemini
kullan
yöntemini uygula diyelim yöntemini
uygula Peki ben şimdi işlemsel olarak
buraya tekrarla çıkarma yöntemini
uygulamak istiyorum nedir çıkarma
yöntemi tekrarlı çıkarma yöntemi A'dan
B'yi çıkartıyorum
16'dan 5'i çıkart çıkartım kalan kaç
yazıyorum 16'dan 5 çıktı yazabilirsin
bunu işlemsel olarak da yazsan yanlış
olmaz 16'dan 5 çıktı kalan kaçtır 11
şöyle de yazsan yanlış olmaz 16'dan 5
çıktı eşittir cevap nedir 11'dir bu
şekilde de yazabilirsin ya da uzun uzun
böyle yazabilirsin Peki bitti mi
Normalde bölme işlemi nereye kadar gider
kalan değer bölen değerden tabii bak
dedim ya sana temel matematik bilgisini
bilmek zorundasın Örneğin A sayısını
B'ye bölüyorsun buradaki ifade nedir
kalan ama bölmenin tanımlı olabilmesi
için kalan değerin kimde küçük Hatta
eşit olmaması gerekiyor bölenden küçük
olması gerekiyor bizim temel felsefemiz
bu şimdi 11 sayısı hala daha 5'ten büyük
olmaz diyorum O zaman devam edeceğim
işleme 11'den artık arka planda kaçı
çıkartacak yine bizim programımız 5'i
çıkartacak 11'den 5 çıktığında kalan kaç
olacaktır 6 olacaktır Hatta burada
gösterebilirsin 11'den kaçı çıkarttım
5'i Çıkarttım kalan kaç oldu hop 6 oldu
yola devam ettim şimdi 6'dan kaçı
çıkartıyorum 5 çıkartacaksın 5'i
çıkarttığımda artık kalan kaç olacaktır
1 olacaktır E bu ne anlama gelir Hocam
şöyle 10 pardon 6 - 5 = kalan kaç oldu 1
oldu aslında adımlarım Bitti Demek ki
kalan kaçmış birmiş ama benim Bunu
programa anlatmam lazım artık Burada
durması gerektiğini anlatmam lazım O
yüzden şöyle yazıyorum 4 adım ne zaman
duracağını tarif etmem lazım ne zaman
duruyor bir tarif edelim kalan değer
çıkartılan değerden
küçük olduğu anda bir sonraki adıma geç
Eğer kalan değer çıkan değerden büyükse
3 adımı tekrarla bak yazmam gereken
ifade buymuş
Eğer kalan değer kalan değer kalan değer
çıkartılan değerden çıkartılan değerden
değerden çıkartılan değerden küçükse
küçük İse sonraki adıma geç sonraki
adıma geç adıma geç Şimdi tekrar tarif
ediyorum Peki ya büyükse
Eğer kalan
değer kalan değer çıkartılan değerden
çıkartılan çıkartılan değerden değere
diyelim ya da eşit veya büyükse eşit
veya büyükse büyük ise
e 3 adıma geri dön adıma Geri Dön Geri
Dön artık iki tane eğerle başlayan
cümlemi kurdum dedim ki eğer benim kalan
değerim ki kalan değerimi Biz burada kaç
bulduk Mesela şurada işaretleyelim 1
bulduk Eğer kalan
değerim çıkarttığım değerden küçük İse
sonraki adıma geçeceğim yani 4 adım
daydım bir sonraki adım olan 5'e
geçeceğim Eğer kalan değer çıkartılan
değere eşitse veya büyük ise Aa Hocam
mesela 6 adım dayım 3 adımı tekrar
uyguladım gördün mü 6 buldum kalanı o
zaman tekrar çıkartma işlemine devam
ediyor tekrar çıkartma işlemine devam
ediyor şimdi burayı Aslında daha doğru
yazabilmek adına şöyle de yapabilirim
şöyle tekrarlı çıkarma yöntemini kullan
dedim ya orada şöyle bir şey yapacağım
daha net olmak adına hani daha güzel
anlatabilmek adına Hatta burada artık
bölünen sayı bölen sayı şeklinde
tanımlamadır dikkat et çıkartılan sayı
İlk sayı diyelim İlk sayı ilk sayıyı gir
çıkartılan sayıyı gir çıkartılan sayıyı
gir bak biz buna İlk sayı diyelim 16
sayısına çıkartılan sayıyı yani böldüğüm
sayıya da 5 B'yi gireceğim ardından
dedim ki Amacım ne A'dan B'yi çıkartmak
Neyi bulmak kalan değer yani kyi bulmak
diyelim bizim kalan değerimiz de burada
bu olsun K ne olsun kalan değer olsun
bunu tanımlıyorum programa bunu programa
anlatmaya çalışıyorum şimdi ne zamanki
bu kalan değer Eğer kalan değer
çıkartılan değerden küçük İse sonraki
adıma geç dedi Hatta bunu matematiksel
olarak hocam Burada da tarif edebilir
misin Bak yine biraz matematiği
kullanacağım noktalarda Şurayı Sadece
doğru bir şekilde kopart çalışıyorum
Oradan ha kopardım bak burayı şimdi
tarif etmeye çalışacağım nasıl tarif
edeceğim kalan değer yani k değeri
küçükse B'den ne yapıyorum sonraki adıma
geçiyorum kalan değer büyük eşitse B'den
ne yapıyorum 3 adıma geri dönüyorum
buradaki adımların mantığı bu geldim 5
adım artık 5 adım artık ekrana yazdırma
durumu geldi Eğer sonuç Eğer sonuç ya da
kalan değer diyelim sonuç diye bir şey
bilmiyoruz Çünkü kalan değer
Eee kalan değer çıkartılan değerden
küçükse çıkartılan değerden değerden
küçük ise küçük ise
sonucu ekrana yaz ekrana
yaz Bak bu kadar Şimdi burada yapacağı
işlem ne kalan değerimiz kaçtır 1'dir
işte kalan değeri buldu ya en son
yazıyor Artık Neyi bulmaya Çalışıyorduk
biz 16 sayısının 5 ile bölümünden kalan
16 16 sayısının
sayısının 5 ile bölümünden 5 ile
bölümünden
kalan 1ir ekranda yazacak yazısına kadar
her şeyine kadar ne yaptım ayarladım
artık 6 adım dayım programı bitirdik
Çünkü neye yapmam lazım bitirmem
gerekiyor son cümle olarak ne yazdım
programı bitire tıkladım ya da artık
arka planda oluşan işlemi sana aktardım
olay mevzu bu ama farklı sorularla ben
devam edeceğim hiç merak etme kaçıncı
sorud dayım bu 4 soruydu galiba Şimdi
geldik 5 sorumuza hız hız saatte 50 km
olan bir bisikletlinin 150 kilometrelik
bir parkuru tamamlamak için kaç saate
ihtiyaç duyacağını bulan algoritmanın iş
değişiğini algoritmik doğal dille yazın
bak önce problemi kafanda bir çözmeye
çalış karalamaya çöz hocam yol ne kadar
150 km benim hızım ne kadar 50 km saat
50 km saat ne yapılır bu değerler
birbirine bölünür sonuç ne çıkacak 3
saat ha benim yapmam gereken işlem Bu
sayıları birbirine bölmek o halde
diyorum ki sil bunu şimdi kafamda
tasarladım planladım ilk şey neydi
Birinci Adım Öncelikle başla komutunu sö
em gerekiyor başla geldim ikinci adıma
ikinci adımım neydi hız verisini gir
hızını gir ya da kimin hızı bu daha net
konuşalım bisikletlinin hızını gir
bisikletlinin
hızını gir hızını gir Peki
bisikletlerinin hızını Biz B harfi ile
gösterirsek onun hızına Ne yazması
gerekiyor 50 km / saat yazması gerekiyor
Ne gerekiyorsa yazıyorum Aynı adımı
devam edebilirsin ya da Bak şunu yapman
hata olmaz Hocam ben başka adıma
geçeceğim abiciğim Vallahi hata değil
tek bir adımda bütün verileri
isteyebilirsin ya da adım adım
isteyebilirsin Hani bunu şey gibi düşün
önüne bir pencere açılıyor sayfa
açılıyor veri girebileceğin iki tane
boşluk var Birinin yanında diyor ki
Bikinin verisini gir İkinci veride ne
yazıyor işte toplam yolu gir ha Mevzuyu
anladım şimdi başka bir şekilde
Anlatıyorum bunları ben sana tek bir
adımda verdim ekran açıldı Bikinin
verisini gir çıktı bastın veriyi girdin
hop yeni ekran açıldı şimdi diyor ki
toplam yolu gir toplam mesafeyi gir abi
bunu tek adımda da verebilirim 3 adımda
da verebilirim ben tek adımda verme
taraftarıyım bunları şimdi toplam
parkuru tamamlamak için parkurun
parkurun uzunluğunu gir diyelim parkurun
uzunluğunu gir parkurun uzunluğunu gir
uzunluğunu gir peki Buraya Ne yazacaksın
Sen parkurun uzunluğuna Eğer ben p
dersem buraya yazman gereken mesafe 50
km Tabii ki bu veriler değişse de bu
program mavi kısma baktığımızda hep ne
yapacak aslında çalışacak siyah kısım Bu
soru özelinde benim bu programda
verileri yazacağım ifadeler geldim 3ün
adıma artık değeri hesaplamam gerekiyor
neye hesaplamak istiyorum parkurun
tamamlamak için kaç saate ihtiyacı
olduğunu gerekli olan saate hesapla
parkuru tamamlamak için parkuru
tamamlamak için tamamlamak için gerek
saat gerekli olan saati hesapla gerekli
olan saati hesapla Peki bunu nasıl
hesaplayacak adam hesaplamak için benim
ona veriyi vermem lazım Gerekli saat
gerekli saat gerekli saat eşittir ne
yaptıracağım Matematiksel işlem
yaptıracağım Kimi kime böldü ceğim
parkur uzunluğunu parkur uzunluğunu bölü
işareti de tıpkı o hesap makinelerindeki
işlem gibi yapıyoruz kime bölüyorum
bisikletin hızına
bisikletin hızına yukarıda yazdığım
veriyle aynı şeyi yazmam lazım Peki
matematiksel olarak bulacağımız değer
gerekli olan saatimiz şu olsun tamamını
[__] için gerekli olan saatimiz T
olsun parkurun uzunluğuna p demiştik p
değerini neye böleceğim bisikletlinin
hızına da B demiştik şimdi verilerle
yazıyorum T değeri eş 150 bölü ne olacak
arka planda işlem olarak ne yapacak
bilgisayar 150'yi 50'ye bölecek
otomatikman buradan 150/50 ne bulacak 3
saat Bulacak şimdi o veriyi bana
aktarması lazım değil mi 4 adıma artık
geldim 4 adımda ne yapacağım veriyi
bulduğum sonucu ekrana yazdıracağım Yani
artık şunu yapacağım gerekli saati
gerekli olan saati saati ekrana yaz
saati ekrana yaz ekrana yaz Peki ekrana
Aslında ne yazacak bu adam şöyle şuradan
bakalım parkuru tamamlamak için gerekli
saat parkuru parkuru tamamlamak için
tamamlamak için x saate ihtiyacı vardır
Tabii x demeyeceğim neyle belirtmiştim t
ile belirtmiştim T saate ihtiyaç vardır
ihtiyaç vardır Burası tamamen Senin
hayal gücüne kalmış Hani gerekli olan
saatdir yaz bitir Abim bu sana kalmış
benim programımın ana ekranında ben şunu
yazsın istiyorum parkurun tamamlanması
için gerekli olan saat T saattir ya da
parkuru tamamlamak için T saate ihtiyaç
vardır bitti bu kadar ha Benim Ekranımda
gerçekte ne yazacak Peki parkuru
tamamlamak için tamamlamak için bu bütün
sayılar ne olursa olsun yazacağı ifade
benim Ekranımda bitişinde artık ne
yazacak 3 saate ihtiyaç vardır ihtiyaç
vardır Al sana benim Ekranımda yazması
gereken ifade olay bu bitti mi Medi
artık programı Kapatmam lazım 5 adıma
geldim bunu asla unutmuyorsun buradan
kesin puan kırılır arkadaşım bitir
diyorsun bu kadar Anlaştık mı Biliyorum
çok kolay değil ama ilk seferde zorlana
da zorlana da olsa bu işi öğreteceğim
ben sana Mesela daha chet refi bir soru
6 sorumuz biraz daha böyle chet revelli
bir soru bir bakalım Ona Emre
mahalledeki hayvanları beslemek için bir
torb mamı almak istiyor Babası ona 150 T
para veriyor pet shop'a git diyor Eğer
bir torba mamanın fiyatı 150 veya daha
azsa al paranın üstüyle eve dön Eğer
fiyatı 150'den fazlaysa Almadan geri gel
mama Almadan geri gel demiştir Buna göre
emrenin görevi yerine getirirken
izleyeceği adımları belirten algoritmayı
yaz adeta Hayatta başka hiçbir bilgisi
olmayan sadece seni dinleyip dediklerini
harfiyen uygulayan birine adım adım bu
süreci anlatmalıyım Yani ben bu süreci
şöyle de anlatabilirim iki yumurta al
tavada kır bana omlet
aktar tane tane anlatman lazım işte
burada da bunu yapıyoruz aslında tane
tane bu işlemleri anlatıyoruz Birinci
Adım Birinci Adım ne Tabii ki başta
komutuyla başlıyorsun ikinci adım ikinci
Adım orada bir başlay yazmış mıyız diye
merak ettim birinci adımını yazmışım
tamam Bir an unuttum öyle yazmamış
olabilir miyim dedim geldim ikinci adıma
ikinci adımda ne yapacağım önce veriyi
almam lazım Emre'nin parasını yaz
Emre'nin Emre'nin
parasını gir parasını gir
şimdi bize bir ne lazım Emre'nin
elindeki paranın miktarı lazım değil mi
Emre'nin parasını gir buraya nokta
diyelim Emre'nin parasını ne ile
gösterelim Emre'nin parası Emre'nin
parası e olsun Mesela e değil belliymiş
ya Emre'nin parasına e diyelim Hatta o
para kaç tlm miş 150l babasının verdiği
ücret Ona neymiş 150 şimdi Emre ne
yapacak adım adım yazıyoruz pet shop'a
git 3 adım 3 adım pet shop'a gidilir
Eğer bir torba mamanın fiyatı mamanın
Fiyatı belli mi belli değil pet shop'a
gidilir pet shop'a gidilir mamanın
fiyatı öğrenilir bak önce bunu yapması
gerekiyor gidilir
mamanın fiyatı öğrenilir fiyatı
öğrenilir
öğrenilir mamanın fiyatını gir yazalım
şimdi öğrendik ya mamanın fiyatını gir
öğrendin artık fiyatını gir diyelim ki
öğrendin geldin buraya mamanın fiyatını
Biz şöyle gösterelim x ile gösterelim
mamayı mamanın fiyatı x T olsun Hatta
şöyle yazalım henüz mamay la ilgili
başka bir bilgimiz yok artık ne
yapabilirim 4ü adıma geçebilirim 4 adım
şimdi mamanın fiyatı var elimde Emre'nin
parası var elimde bunları ne yapacağım
Eğer bir torba mamanın fiyatı 150 veya
daha azsa Al şimdi aldırmaya çalışacağım
diyorum ki Eğer şimdi buradaki eğeri
şuradan başlatacağım Çünkü bir de
alamayacağı durumu yazacağım sonrasında
adım adım Eğer mamanın fiyatı mamanın
fiyatı Emre'nin parasından Emre'nin
parasına eşit veya Emre yazamadım
yazmıyor He Emre'nin Emre'nin
parasına parasına
eşit
veya daha az ise daha az ise mamayı al
mama yı al şimdi mamayı alacağı durumu
tarif ettin mi ettim mamayı alacağı
durumu tarif etmeme rağmen işlemim
Aslında daha bitmedi dikkat et mamayı
alacak Ama bir de Para üstü olacak Para
üstünü al eve dön şimdi bir alt kademe
olduğu için ben biraz daha içeri doğru
yaklaşıyorum burada ama dikkat et bir de
şöyle bir ihtimal var bunların ikisini
birden aynı anda yazmak istiyorum ki
sana daha net göstereyim şimdi Birinci
durumun gerçekleşmesi mamanın fiyatının
Emre'nin parayla olan İliş isini
gösteriyor Eğer ki Emre'nin parasına
eşitse mamanın fiyatı veya daha ie
mamayı alacak ama alt basamağı var onu
yazacağım şimdi yazacağım ama eğer başka
bir durum varsa Yani şöyle bir durum
Eğer mamanın fiyatı Emre'nin parasından
büyük ise Emre'nin
parasın dan parasından büyük ise büyük
ise mamayı alma mamayı alma eve gel eve
gel öyle de demiyor mu bak bakalım ne
diyor Eğer fiyatı 150 TL'den fazlaysa
Almadan geri gel Süpersin Şimdi şöyle
bir şey yapalım burayı işletebilmek için
mamayı almadan eve gelmesini
işletebilmek için x değerinin ne
olmasını istiyorsun 150'den büyük
olmasını istiyorsun işlemsel olarak
böyle bir şey var peki diğer durumda
Eğer mamanın fiyatı Emre'nin parasına
eşit veya daha azsa mamayı al işlemsel
olarak nasıl bir şey işleyecek arka
planda x lira Eğer 150 t'ye eşit veya
daha küçükse ne yapacaksın mamayı
alacaksın Şimdi mamayı aldığımı kabul
ediyorum artık ne yaptım mamayı aldım Ne
yapacağım Para üstünü hesaplayacağız ne
diyor bak paranın üstüyle eve dön Para
üstünü hesapla Para üstünü üstünü
hesapla Ben makineye diyorum ki mamayı
aldık ama bize Para üstü lazım Daha bu
adımı uygularken Benim ne yapmam
gerekiyor Para üstünü hesaplatmak Para
üstü nasıl hesaplanır para üstü Para
üstü eşittir nasıl bulunur Para üstü
Emre'nin parası Emre'nin
parası eksi parası eksi mama fiyatı
yazılınca neye ulaşmış olacağım Para
üstü fiyatına ulaşmış olacağım peki bunu
yine nasıl yazmak zorundayım Arkadaş
Yukarıdaki gibi matematiksel sembollerle
de yazmak zorundayım para üstüne bundan
sonra p diyelim eşittir Bu p değeri
Emre'nin parasına e demiştik aldığımız
şey parasına da mama parasına da x
demiştik e - xile ifade edilecek ha
Tabii ki buradaki e değeri belli yani
şöyle de yazmamda hata yok p = 150 - x
şeklinde de ne yapabilirim yazabilirim
şimdi eğer mama fiyatı Emre'nin parasına
eşit veya dahae mamayı aldık işlemleri
gösterdik bir ihtimal daha var dedik O
ihtimal neydi Eğer mamanın fiyatı
Emre'nin parasından büyük ise mamayı
alma eve gel dedik onu da gösterdik
artık BT bütün durumları gösterdiğim
göre sonuca gidebilirim yani kaçıncı
adıma gidiyorum artık 5 adıma gidiyorum
yani Bu bulduğum değerleri ekrana
yazdırıp göstermem lazım yalnız ekranda
da iki farklı durum var Nasıl olacak iki
farklı durumu da izah etmem gerekiyor
birinci durum Eğer mama alındı ise
alındı ise ekrana ekrana Ne yazsın mama
alındı Para üstü işte XP TL öyle yazsın
mama alındı mama
alındı Para üstü Para üstü Ay yazamadım
Para üstü p TL'dir ne yapacağız bunu
yazdıracağız Peki bizim gerçek ekranımı
da ne yazacak istersen onu da yazalım
biliyorsun ki ben onları siyahla
yazıyorum mama alındı mama alındı alındı
Para üstü Para üstü A burada Gerçi değer
olarak yazamayacağı Çünkü mama değeri
belli değil p TL'dir bizim Ekranımda
gözükecek olan ifade bu ha bir ihtimal
daha var ekranda yazacak olan ifade onu
da belirtmem lazım Eğer mama alınamaz
ise
alınamaz ise ekrana Ne yazsın burada
Paşa Gönlüm biliyor gerçekten mama
alınamadı yazsın mama alınamadı yazsın
mama alınamadı
alınamadı yaz şimdi onu da bizim
ekranlarda gözükecek şekilde belirtelim
nasıl gözüksün bizim ekranda da mama
alınamadı mama
[Müzik]
alınamadı güzel artık sonuca geldim
ekranda da yazdırdığım göre 6 bir adımı
yazıyorum programı kapatıp bitirmem
gerekiyor 6 adım nedir bitir komutuyla
ne yaptım programı da burada bitirdim
Efsane bir soru dahayi Ey güzel
arkadaşım efsane sorular biter mi bizde
bitmez gelsin 7 sorumuz Biliyorum çok
yeni bir konu öğretmenlerimizin de
anlatırken zorlanabilir bir konu Çünkü
ben de öğretmenlik Hayatımda ilk defa bu
konuyu anlatıyorum ama bilgisayarla
Allah'tan aram çok iyi o yüzden bunları
aktarması biraz daha kolay oluyor diye
düşünüyorum şimdi geldim 7 soruya bir
robotun tamir için gerekli malzeme
listesi şu şekildir Ben olsam mesela
bunu sınavda kesin sorardım abi 2 adet
vida her biri 5 t 3 adet somun Her biri
3 TL bir adet motor 50 robotun bu
malzemeler için toplam maliyeti bulan
algoritmanın işleyişini algoritmik doğal
dil ile yazınız bak sınav sorumuz Bu
nasıl yazacağım hocam birinci adımla
başlayacağım Tabii ki Birinci Adım neydi
başlayacağım diyorum başta komutunu
veriyorum yani geldim ikinci adıma
ikinci adım verileri toplayacağız
toplayacağım verileri tek bir seferde
toplamak istiyorum toplamak istediğim
veriler olayı şu bana vidanın tane
fiyatı gerekli bak yazıyorum
vidanın birleşik yazabiliriz değil mi
buraya ayrca gerek yok vidanın tane
birim fiyatı diyelim ya aynı anlama
geliyor biliyorsun birim fiyatı Peki
birim fiyatını gir yazdım Peki bu fiyatı
neyle girsin Örneğin bana V = 5L olarak
girsin ne dersin aynı anlama gelsin
bunlar ardından neye girecek somun birim
fiyatını gir birim fiyatını gir fiyatın
bu somun ekmek değil ha fiyatı gir somun
hani şu şey var ya yuvarlak geldim
somunun fiyatını giriyorum somunun
fiyatı neymiş S = 3 onu da girdim her
birine harf vermen işleri kolay ştı
biliyor motor birim fiyatını gir motor
birim fiyatı gir fiyatı gir Mesela ben
istiyorum ki Benim programım Evet
bunların her birini burada topladı güzel
ama bir de bana ne lazım Normal
şartlarda bir kere şunu söylemeyi
unuttum herhalde problemi çözebilmek
için genel mantığım ne hocam 2 ile 5'i
Çarpacağım 10 3 ile 3'ü Çarpacağım 9 TL
bir adet bundan aldığıma göre 50 TL
bunları toplayacağız cevaba gideceğiz
değil mi 69 Hocam cevap bitti Ama öyle
olmuyor işte ne yapacağım Bun adım adım
giriyorum ikinci adımda birim fiyatları
aldım karşı taraftan ama bunu ayrı bir
adımda almak istedi Canım istersen yine
sen ikinci adımın içerisinde de
alabilirsin yanlış olmaz bunun yanlışı
doğrusu yok Sen programın nasıl
çalışmasını istiyorsan öyle gir 3üncü
adımda Ben şunu istiyorum adet
fiyatlarını istiyorum vida adet fiyatını
gir adet Pardon adet fiyatını girdik
vida adedini gir adet
gir kaç adet alacak onu girmesini
istiyorum adet fiyatını girerken ne
kullansın mesela a kullansın adet fiyatı
ne 2 bunu girecek küçü a kullandım somun
adet fiyatını gir adet adetini fiyat
değil tane hesabı yapıyoruz artık
adetini gir Bunu B olarak kullanacağım B
olarak ne kullanacağım 3 mü 3 adet somun
alıyor güzel geldim somun değil somun
sonrasında motor adetini gir motor adeti
gir motordan kaç tane alıyor bir tane
alıyor Bunu da C olarak gireceğim bundan
da bir tane alıyor artık işlemleri
yaptıracağım 4 adım toplam maliyeti
hesaplamak istiyorum e adımın ismi o
olsun o zaman toplam maliyeti maliyeti
hesapla Peki toplam maliyet nasıl
hesaplanır bunu bir formülle onu
anlatmam gerekiyor toplam maliyet toplam
mali ya da toplam maliyeti şöyle
hesaplayalım
vida maliyeti önce vida maliyetini
hesaplasın vida maliyeti vida maliyeti
nedir eşittir vida birim fiyatı birim
fiyatı artık sen anla çarpı vida adet
Anladık mı peki geldim diğerine biraz
daha sola doğru çekeceğim matematiksel
işlemlerini yanına yazabilmek adına
hocam vidanın maliyeti vidanın maliyeti
VM olsun vida birin fiyatına ne dedik V
dedik çarpı vida ad ne dedik a dedik Bak
bu kadar işlem ne yapacağını tarif
ediyorum şimdi somon somon maliyeti bunu
hesaplatılır
[Müzik]
biliyorum uzuyor gibi olabilir ama bence
çok net oluyor böyle ve tam puanı
getirecektir bize motor birim fiyatı
çarpı motor nesini girecek adetini
girecek Peki bunu nasıl hesaplayacak
motor maliyeti eşittir ne demiştik
motorun maliyeti için m x c demiştik
şimdi bu işlemleri de benim arka planda
yaptırmam lazım O yüzden ben bu tarafta
yapıyorum
Eee şöyle yapalım vida maliyeti eş ne
ile Neyi çarpıyorum 2 ile 5'i çarptım ne
elde ettim 10 elde ettim devam ettim
somon maliyetini hesaplıyorum somon
maliyeti için 3 ile 3'ü çarptım ne elde
ettim 9 TL elde ettim artık motor
maliyetini hesaplıyorum 1 ile 50'yi
çarpıyorum cevap ne geldi 50 geldi artık
matematiksel işlemlere gösterdim ya 5
adıma geçiyorum ha 5 adıma geçmeyelim
Biz zaten burada ne demişiz dikkat et
toplam maliyeti hesapla şimdi aynı
adımın içerisinde toplam mal hesapla
toplam maliyet eşittir toplam maliyet ne
şekilde bulunabilir vida maliyeti vida
maliyeti Art somon maliyeti Art motor
maliyeti motor maliyeti Şimdi bunu
formülle anlatmaya çalışıyorum toplam
maliyet TM olsun vida maliyeti Art somon
maliyeti Art motor maliyeti güzel şimdi
bu işlemleri yapıp cevabı bulmak
istiyorum 10 + 9 TL + 50l sonuç toplam
maliyet eşittir ne geldi 69 TL Aman
Allah'ım Sadece bu kadar kolay bir
işlemi adeta Affedersin bir geri
zekalıya anlatır gibi anlatmazsan
olmuyor işlemiyor bu adımlar şimdi bunu
ekrana yazdırmam gerekiyor geldim 5
adıma 5 adımı yazmaya çalışıyorum ha 5
adım toplam maliyeti ekrana yaz toplam
maliyeti maliyeti ekrana
ekrana yazdır ya da yaz Fark etmez O
halde toplam maliyet Bak tam ekrana
yazmasını istediğim şey şu toplam
maliyet maliyet ne olacak benimkinde
Hatta Önce şöyle bir maviyle yazayım
maviyle görmüş ol Ne yazacağımız genel
yazı şu olacak aslında ben sayı girdiğim
için direkt sayıyı görebileceğim toplam
maliyet TM TL'dir Şimdi bak benim
buradaki TM ben girdikten sonra bende şu
şekilde gözükecek toplam maliyet
maliyet 60 TL'dir hop hop hop güzel
arkadaşım toplam maliyet Ya bak o kadar
şey yazıyorsun şurada ha
69 olur diyelim ardından 6 adımla bitir
dedik Anlaştık mı arkadaş benim sana
burada anlatmak istediğim Özellikle bu
Maviler Bu programın hangi sayıları
girersen gir sana vereceği çıktı Eğer bu
girersen siyahlarla yapılan işlemler de
siyahla yazdıklarımda siyahla bana O
bilgisayar programın bana çıktısı dır
Nedir o toplam maliyet 60 TL'dir benim
Ekranımda gözükecek olan şey artık 6
adıma geldim 6 adımda ne diyorum
bitirebilirim olay bitmiştir dedim bitir
dedim mükemmel bir soruyu daha geride
bıraktım Ama çözümü anlamam benim için
çok kıymetli Ben daha fazlasını senin
için burada yapmak için hazırım senden
isteğim var yalnız videonun yorumlar
kısmına iniyorsun ve yorumlara bu
sorunun cevabını adım adım yazıyorsun
hediyeli bir soru olsun ne hediye
vereceğiz bilemedim şimdilik ama yani bu
hediyeyi düşünürüz Ya sen yeter ki yaz
en çok beğenilen çözüme hediyeyi
gönderiyorum Arkadaş ne zaman ara
tatilden bir gün önce bakacağım Hediye
göndereceğim arkadaşlar o arkadaşa bir
bayram hediyesi bayramda Gerçi bayramdan
önce göndermem lazım dur tarih bakalım
ya öyle Karam böle sınavlardan önce Evet
evet sınavdan bir gün önce sınavdan
sınav günü göndereceğim hediyeyi sınav
günü göndereceğim sınavımız 25 Mart Salı
günü müydü öyle hatırlıyorum Bir dakika
takvimimi açayım yanlışlık olmasın Evet
25 Mart salı günüydü 25 Mart Salı günü
Sizler sınavdayken bu videonun
yorumlarına inip en çok beğeni alan Bu
sorunun çözümünü adım adım tane tane
anlatan arkadaşa benden Gönlümden bir
hediye vallahi böyle bir güzellik de
yapmış olalım diyelim Ey güzel arkadaşım
elimden geldiğince dilim döndüğünce
herkesin zorlandığı öğretmenin
öğrencisine 5 tema Algoritma Bilişim hiç
merak etme o iş bizde beraber Bu dersi
de bu konuyu da halledeceğiz matematik
bizde Güvener Sen diğerlerini hallet ki
ekstra soru çözümleri derece tayfası
çözümleri elbet gelecek o iş dedik ya
biz de re Tayfa Yolun açık olsun Bir
sonraki derste görüşelim Kendine iyi bak
hoş kal Hoşça kal
[Müzik]
h